and sometimes I think when working with
you you think we know the rules Abby
it's your way or the highway
moms are constantly questioning your
methods and it drives you up the walls
if only they could realize that their
comments make things worse for their
daughters you really pulled out all the
stops in season eight it's just too bad
that your rule book goes out the window
whenever someone's pipe gets hurt
the cast of Dance Moms has a hard time
following every single one of Abby's
super strict rules and we can't say we
really blame them if you disrespect
Abby's wishes your kid might find
themselves at the bottom of the pyramid
breaking any of these rules can result
in a dancers or mothers immediate
expulsion
keep watching to get all the deets don't
talk about other Studios Abby Lee Miller
has gotten more than a few verbal fights
with michelle dorr Dianna in season
eight most of them revolve around
Michelle still being in contact with
studio 19 which is why Abby came up with
one simple rule no one is allowed to
utter another Studios name in her
presence but unfortunately for Sarah
Michelle spoke out about studio 19 mid
rehearsal which resulted in her daughter
being kicked out of the group routines
rules are rules Michelle reap what you
sow Abby doesn't believe in handouts
especially not when it comes to the ALDC
dancers who prove themselves by putting
in the extra work are we born with solos
and those who don't just aren't finding
out that she was one of the weakest
dancers of the group was a hard pill for
Gia Nia to swallow five in an extended
team from season eight Abby rewarded
national solos to Presley Brady and
slily
which led to Giannina asking Abby for an
explanation well turns out that Giannina
just wasn't good enough to land a solo
oh no that's gotta hurt be the best but
don't outshine the others Dance Moms
fans received the shock of their
lifetime when Abby chose to boot Brady
Farrar off the show Brady is going
this came as a total surprise because of
how talented Brady was he was the best
dancer at the ALDC and it came back to
haunt it one of Abby's rules is to
always be the best but in Brady's case
being the best was harming the group's
dynamic so in season 8 episode 5 Abby
chose to send Brady home until the rest
of her dancers could get their acts
together no moms in the studio no moms
in the studio is the oldest rule at the
ALDC
but for some reason mothers just can't
help but barge into the studio during
rehearsals in season 8 Michelle was
continuously kicked out of the ALDC for
disrespecting this rule so much so that
her own daughter became annoyed with her
one time Sarah was so fed up with her
mom's requests that she asked her get it
together Michelle no moms in the studio
don't question the teachers in season 8
episode 1 Stacey Ketchum questioned Abby
in front of the entire group and she
would later regret it
Stacey was angry because Lily placed 3rd
in a macro solo which she believes to be
Abby's fault
so Abby reminded her mom's talk kids
play in that very same episode
Abby laid out the law like it was
everyone's business when Stacey wouldn't
stop a raving Abby with questions about
Lily's acro solo Abby blew a fuse she
told Stacey that she shouldn't question
her because she didn't know anything and
when Stacey said that Lily didn't have
to do acro dances every week Abby
reminded her that she didn't have to do
any dances Abby won't hesitate to punish
a mother's kid when she acts out of line
so while you're ahead Stacey call the
cops first ask questions later
on more than one occasion Abby has
called the cops on her students mothers
or people who went out of their way to
mess with her in an extended scene from
season 8 Tami from studio 9 harasses the
moms of the ALDC and tells Abby to put
your phone away
and it's the last straw for Abby the
dance teacher immediately files a police
report Abby's way or the highway in
season eight episode six Joanne forbade
her daughter from performing her Snooki
solo and Abby was livid refusing to do a
solo is a big deal
and Giannina paid the price for her
mother's decision Abby made it clear
that another solo wouldn't be coming
Gia's way for a long time due to Joanne
not being able to keep her mouth shut
no mistakes allowed Abby gave Lily the
ultimatum in season 8 episode 6 Stacey
was quick to come to her kids defense
but Abby's decision was final making
mistakes isn't an option no matter how
difficult the choreography may be and
Abby isn't one to that tiny mistake slip
past her leave the drama at the door
everyone is tired of Michelle and studio
19 ever since Michelle and Sarah joins
the ALDC their old studio has been
messing up the group's dynamic and Abby
and the other moms have had enough the
number one rule that the ALDC is to
leave your drama at the door who is your
favorite mother-daughter duo from season
eight of Dance Moms sound off in the
comments and that's a wrap thanks for
watching give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things we'll catch you next time